[Music]
studies of children have shown that we
are born with this instinct for what's
called substance dualism the idea that
the MA the body and the mind or soul
however you want to think of the psyche
are separate children who as young as
three or four years old who have not
grown up with any kind of religious
instruction naturally assume that they
have a soul and so I think a lot of
theorists believe that this is this
belief in the soul is universal that it
can be traced back deep into our
evolution why there's a whole host of
reasons for that
I mean I suppose that if you're an
unbeliever you think that it's just some
kind of evolutionary accident it's a
trick of the mind if as it were that
makes you think that you are an
immaterial being inside a material body
if you're a believer you think that it's
probably because there is a soul and
maybe perhaps that we were intentionally
created in such a way as to think that
there is more to us than just the
material realm it's really a choice but
what cannot be denied is that belief in
the soul is a belief that all peoples
share regardless of their culture or
their religion and it's a belief that
goes back as far back in time as we can
possibly trace it and if these
psychological studies that I was talking
about our right it's a belief that were
born with over the last couple of
hundred years there's been an enormous
amount of thought that's gone into the
question of why religion you know the
one thing that we all agree on is that
religion has been a part of the human
experience from the beginning in fact we
can trace the origin of religious
experience to before homo sapiens we can
shape we can trace it with some measure
of confidence to me
and earth all's we can measure it with a
little less confidence all the way to
Homo erectus so we're talking hundreds
of thousands of years before our species
even existed so the question is why
you know if religion is a universal
phenomenon or rather I should say
religious experience
if religious experience is a universal
phenomenon if it can be traced in all
peoples all cultures and throughout all
time then there must be some
evolutionary reason for it there must be
a reason some adaptive advantage to
having religious experience or faith
experience otherwise it wouldn't exist
and so there have been over the last
couple of centuries numerous attempts to
figure out exactly what that adaptive
advantage would be the most popular
explanation of course is the
sociological one that religion creates a
sense of cohesion amongst a group and
that that sense of cohesion the idea
that we could come together and create a
collective identity based on shared
symbols or shared metaphors gave an
adaptive advantage to believing
communities that non believing
communities did not have that's a pretty
good answer the problem is that religion
is as much a divisive issue as it is a
cohesive one it says good at creating
out groups as it is in groups and more
importantly the problem with that the
social cohesion theory is that kinship
was a much more powerful and much more
dominant form of social cohesion than
religion was our ancestors lived in
small communities that were bound
together by by blood by relationship by
by kinship long before they created
symbols and mythologies in order to
unify them so it's a pretty good answer
but it doesn't really
it doesn't really explain what adaptive
advantage religion would have had as
others have said well it's about giving
us you know answers to the the
unanswerable questions of the world that
what it did was create a sense of
knowledge about the universe that
lessened anxiety in some way and that
was an adaptive advantage well even if
that were true and there's truly no
reason scientifically to think that it
was it's really hard to make an argument
about why that would necessarily be an
adaptive advantage particularly because
religion actually causes far more
anxiety than it lessens in fact to put
it in evolutionary terms the cost of
religious expression is enormous it's
enormous in terms of time it's enormous
in in terms of the cognitive processes
that are involved in it it it sort of
creates greater anxiety when you feel as
though your actions have cosmic
significance all of this is to say that
the countless different answers that
have been given for why religion fail
primarily because they're functionalist
answers what they primarily say is what
religion does not why religion exists
and so a group of cognitive scientists
particularly cognitive scientists who
focus on religion have tried to look to
a different way of answering this
question of why religion and what
they've discovered is that number one
there is in the end no adaptive
advantage to religious faith
and number two that the reason that
religion exists it's big is because it
is an accidental byproduct of some other
adaptive advantage and here we get into
very complicated conversations about
cognitive theory and and the development
of our frontal lobes and
things like that but to put it in its
simplest way religious thinking is
embedded in our cognitive processes it
is a mode of knowing we're born with it
it's part of our DNA the question then
becomes why one answer is that there is
no why it's just simply an accident of
other much more important much more
necessary cognitive adaptions
adaptations I should say or if you're a
believer you would say because we were
made that way because we are designed to
believe that there is more to this world
than the material realm but that mode of
knowing that exists in our brain is
there for a reason either answer is fine
there are some people who say well what
religion really does and the reason that
it exists is that it creates some
morality right that if you if we imagine
that there's this absolute moral
lawgiver then we're less likely to kill
our neighbor and that creates some sort
of adaptive advantage the problem with
that theory of course is that the
concept of a moral lawgiver is barely
five thousand years old and religious
expression goes hundreds of thousands of
years I mean if you even think about the
Mesopotamian gods or the Egyptian gods
and this is again six seven eight
thousand years ago these were not moral
beings on the contrary they were amoral
and often immoral being so the idea that
religion is about morality is a very new
idea
others say that religion is about
Authority it's a it's a way of
maintaining control and power over a
group and perhaps those groups that were
religiously inclined had an adaptive
advantage because that notion of an
authority structure allowed them to
survive better again that's a pretty
good answer the problem is is that
you're talking about institutionalized
religious expression which maybe
is 12 to 14 thousand years old that's as
far back as we can trace anything that
looks like an institutional religious
authority and again that does not
explain why religion existed hundreds of
thousands of years before that the truth
of the matter is we just don't know but
what is a fact is that there is
something in the way that our brains
work that compel us to believe that we
are more than just the sum of our
material parts that thing is either an
echo or an accident or it's deliberate
and purposeful and which you decide is
purely a matter of choice because there
is no proof either way
[Music]
you